au qg de goma c'est là que les problèmes
complexes et souvent contradictoires ont
été résolues avec doigté en douceur le
tout était d'allier fermeté et
diplomatie humanitaire et militaire
car en période de crise dit qu il motive
l'intervention de l'aide internationale
les secours se font toujours si ce n'est
à l'abri des fusils au moins d'une force
potentielle celle ci était française
avec à sa tête jean claude lafourcade
général de brigade
sur le départ le quartier général
installé dans un entrepôt vétus de
friperie n'était pas fait pour le luxe
et les réceptions les biens pour
l'efficacité heure par heure le flux de
la population et mesurer analyser le
nombre de morts enregistrés les besoins
consignés et transmis le terrain n'est
jamais négliger l'armée vaccine dans le
camp de mugunga cinquante mille enfants
sont attendus ce n'est pas simple la
misère est grande
pourtant les rwandais pour confiance est
revenue à paris mais militaire et
humanitaire
mais je crois depuis le début de notre
action ça rime bien travaillé ça moins
efficace est mis hors course qui
reprenait un peu de monde mais qui ont
décidé de milly et des milieux 20 et
chaud le terrain à la zone humanitaire
sur ce le même
le médecin est là j'avais les aliments
ferrari en général ce que vous êtes un
autre mort entre nous je parle j'ai un
peu mûri
après quitté l'édifice et
il est réconfortant également de voir
comment les hommes français venu avec
moi est capable de se dévouer de se
dépenser avec nos menus garçon ordinaire
pour une noble cause
les français n'ont pas tenu compte du
regard des autres ils sont venus les
premiers sous les huées ils repartent
aujourd'hui avec les regrets on les
aurait bien garder encore un peu les
besoins sont énormes